[Music]
a few episodes ago on the bob odenkirk
interview we did a segment at the end
where
it just kind of came out of you
naturally that you should star
in a blockbuster movie called whirlygig
where you are this superhero who's still
from the waist up but
has vicious weapon flailing feet below
right
yeah it's actually not just the feet
it's the legs uh i have a
disproportionate body
shorter torso extremely extremely long
legs and so i love the idea that
uh my upper half would remain perfectly
still
in frame and that my lower extremities
my two
long long long thin legs would whip
around
like those you know inflated uh kind of
puppets
in front of a car dealership but have
two of those they'd just be called
whirligig
and the sound would be and they would
just whip around
two of those would just whip around like
[Music]
and i would defeat my foes but my torso
would remain perfectly still and my face
would remain impassive
expressionless well we also put out a
call for some fan art and posters for
the film
and people have delivered we've got
three really nice ones here today but
before we even get to that
someone also went so far as to write and
record
a theme song to the film
[Music]
that can whirligig grab his legs
[Music]
[Applause]
wow oh wow my hat is off to
what this gentleman what is his name
again his name is barnacle
joe of course it is ah
boy the way he gets those h's in in a
whirly gig
yeah see that's what the gig and that
was great i mean i feel like that's
gonna sell
just based on that song barnacle joe
fantastic job
really good that was that was impressive
and uh now i'll show you some posters
first up is from jessie leahy and this
is uh
conan in a kilt with weird fleshy
octopus legs
oh that's pretty good it's not quite
what i i
first of all i would not be smiling i
would be my it's got to be a
just an expressionless cold look but not
bad i still think it's more about the
legs
hinging up from the hips as opposed to
the knees
yeah but um but i like this i like this
and it's it's very well done
it's very well rendered so i would
probably uh
if this person was here make a few
suggestions here and there
uh to nudge it closer to my vision but
this is pretty close
it's a good pull quote though i was
gonna say the same thing
yeah read it the list of requests not to
see it is quite long the wall street
journal yes
[Laughter]
still not the worst review i've ever had
so there you go
and then uh next up is from julius sutin
this is quite oh wow wow
look at that yeah look at that matt we
wrote it
we wrote this movie oh my god we did
yeah very good julius i like also you've
got
the leg to torso ratio just right that
is actually
probably correct is that your butt no
that's the jacket coming down oh you're
right it is it's the jacket coming down
no no the minute uh i have an actual
three-dimensional ass everyone knows
that it's not real because that's what
it is that makes it unreal
yeah it's the jacket so that's the
jacket but uh that's very good
look at the best like the awards
festival awards best drama best legs and
most historically accurate
it's a very uh you know what i love i
love um
getting even more americans to waste
their time and energy
on projects that don't move the puzzle
piece forward for humanity but these are
great all right this is from katie
fischell
and um it's got kind of a classic
universal monsters feel
i love that uh that's that's quite good
and katie what kitty has correctly
rendered
is the legs shooting out from the hip
area
uh and she also has me wearing the uh
early 1980s nba basketball shorts
a lot of attention to detail and the
look on my face is correct
this is very good and the reactions of
the horrified people
seeing my those are really hairless legs
those are
are they or is that stubble or freckles
uh
i think those are not it's not pleasant
whatever it is
it captures oh i said my legs are like
spam
i think so yeah those are oh blotches uh
freckly blotches
that's quite good that is quite good
yeah and it says
they were just trying to go to the
metropolitan museum of art i think it
drives home the fact that your
character kills innocent people yes yes
yes people that don't just nothing
they've done nothing wrong
uh and it's very random yeah just very
random
very good work i'm very impressed again
by the creativity
uh of our fans you know and i'm often i
forget what the riff was in the first
place and then i see and i go oh my god
what the hell you know but thank you
that was great